open the meeting on
the special committee for the Family
Division of the Circuit Court I finally
got it
a few things for us and I'll repeat them
at the end the next time we meet will be
the first Tuesday Morning of October
and uh
that will be a work session
those of I think it's just Pat long uh
no maybe maybe you too the there's a
work session on retained bills in the
morning and the afternoon and children
and family law but this committee will
be in the morning I I wanted to do that
to spare people extra trips yeah October
3rd
um
we will be
trying to finalize the sub groups do you
have any of that information handy with
you if you could bring
bring that up because not everybody has
gotten back to us as to which of these
subgroups they want to be part of and
I'd like to get that buttoned up in the
next few weeks
these groups I would like to work
on their own it is public so it'll have
to be noticed but I want to make up the
final appointment of who and who will be
uh spearheading that who is the
subcommittee chair and things like that
so we can all start working along and
while I'm saying that
um when people have asked me when do I
hope to get done
and the answer is when we have good work
product
the deadline for this committee to
Sunset is next year
um probably October
uh I don't want to rush things
if it's worth doing it's worth doing
right
some of the topics should be very quick
should be pretty obvious there seems to
be a consensus building others are going
to take a lot longer
some of the work products will simply be
communicated to the Judiciary it will
not go into a bill I've been saying this
from day one I just want to say it again
already on the subject of
entry education for new judges and
continuing education the
chief justice invited me up to the law
library last week he gave me a library
card that frightens me because it's 10
cents a day if your book is late in
Hampstead I don't know what it would be
if you stiff the Supreme Court's Library
so I'm I don't know but anyway he uh he
said you know that suggestion that has
been being talked about we're starting
to talk about it up here too
and I said well great let's uh let's
share but I think the fact is some of
the things that are not terribly
controversial uh they're listening to
[Music]
I had asked and I thank
several of you I know numbers of you
have extended email networks on the
subject of the court and I uh tried to
encourage you to tell your network that
what we will be doing today is actually
what committees normally do and that is
to hear people who have not testified
before
I have been very lacks in that we've
actually had a few people testifying two
three and even four times and you did
because I let you and I think getting
going it was probably okay but I asked
for people who are not on the list of
those who had previous testified and
that's all I have here uh these pink
cards fit what I've asked so let me just
repeat kind of what we need from you to
give us the useful information that will
help us as we make suggestions to the
courts and as we write bills for the
legislature we hope to enact into law
um
we need to know
those areas where in your experience
either
the system wasn't followed here are the
rules but they weren't followed
or the rules were followed but you kind
of think maybe the rules should be
changed what we don't need don't accept
is accusations against specific judges
oh he's just a crook oh he only or oh
she is on the take or what we we will
not accept that or about the Judiciary
in general
neither will we retry your case so
please do not give us all the specifics
of the case because that's not useful
information to us we just want to know
where there was a hiccup along the way
and
that's very important as that hiccup for
you it either says to us oh that's an
outlier we didn't know about that we may
need to look into that or it tracks with
what we've been hearing from numbers of
other people
and then finally we'll give you five
minutes
the best testimony we heard here in my
opinion
I was clocking it it was three minutes
and 40 seconds excuse me three minutes
and 47 seconds it was precise on the
point brief and hopeful so
with that in mind chair recognizes uh
Lindsay Smith now
um are you with Cynthia Smith
and you can both come up if you wish and
and I take it you're speaking to the
same
situation okay
you have to press the button
thank you the red light Will Go On
there you go
good morning members of the committee I
am Lindsey Smith I am a survivor of
domestic violence and attempted murder
after years of psychological and sexual
abuse by my domestic partner at the time
I petitioned for a restraining order at
the Hampton Police Department on
November 21st of 2021 judge Polly Hall
the 10th Circuit Court granted a
temporary restraining order that same
day
to last 30 days
I believe that the largest mistake was
made then
by moving forward with my case in Civil
Court instead of
Criminal
Court
the police scrolled through pages of
text
from
brick
my
domestic partner at the time
containing veiled threats deranged
statements and blackmail
I presented photos of my entire body
covered in bruises to the court
which they requested
I'm sorry to the police which they
requested I wait to present in court
the domestic violence that I endured and
described was criminal and it should
have been treated as such I did not know
that then
had the hearing been in Criminal Court
my abuser would have had to show up to
defend himself
on October 20th of 2021
I appeared before judge Polly hall for
the final domestic violence hearing with
only my father in tow
as I did not have legal representation
and the court appointed Advocate did not
show up
nor did my abuser he must have been
flagrantly confident that the
petition would be denied I knew very
quickly by the tone of her voice and
facial expressions during the
proceedings that she was not going to
help me
my dad got that Prussian as well as well
in fact this final petition or
restraining order was denied for reason
of in bold letter in bold letters
plaintiff has not been abused
and that thin piece of paper that had
managed to keep Rick away from me for
most of the short 30-day temporary order
was no longer in place because a woman
not qualified to see behavioral patterns
that determine my words under oath were
fake or perhaps unimportant
again he wasn't there
then on November 6 Rick picked up a
pistol that he'd ordered in hookset
one with which he was well acquainted
from usat the firing range
and his supposed time service in the
Army and police force although it was
always difficult for me to know what was
fact or fiction
he was convincing and often Charming
liar
on November 15th just a week following
the gun purchase and two weeks after the
restraining order had been denied Rick
waited outside of my work for me to
leave and then belligerently was
screaming at me in an argument outside
of a
children's gymnastics studio
he then tasered me in a kidnap attempt
and emptied most of his magazine trying
to murder me at close range as I pleaded
on my knees for my life
fortunately of the 12 rounds in the
magazine only three hit my head
one missing my carotid artery by a
fraction of a millimeter
I praise God every day for that
so although despite my
seven brain surgeries in year and a half
in hospitalization
my skull jaw and spine are still
smattered with bullet fragments as you
can see
I can walk around all right with the
brace and I speak pretty well now
however the road has been long and I'm
not quite sure how I've carried on
it baffles me that had this restraining
order been granted Rick would not have
been able to purchase the gun that he
used on me just two weeks later
thank you for your time
would you accept some questions from us
yes okay anybody
when you first went to the police I
believe you said for a restraining order
um did you try to convince them that
you had been physically abused and
showed them the places that would prove
it I showed them the photographs that I
had on my phone that I'd taken over the
months and years okay
um
so you decided to go forward in civil
courts
was not given any sort of
recommendations or options by the police
department they just immediately
um I guess recommended and decided that
a temporary restraining order would be
immediately
appropriately and
that was granted the same day
for a temporary
order
did it seem to you that the judge said
the plaintiff has not been abused
because there was no evidence presented
to that
gotta get the mic back on there you go
that's where my hand doesn't work very
well that statement from the judge was
not until the final
hearing
later
that there had been no abuse so
I believe that she felt that my evidence
presented wasn't Timely
enough
um
because some of the photos were dated in
two or three years prior okay
so
um
I think that was where the decision came
from one of the things I hear from
judges I know personally outside of all
of this is that they can't rule on
something they don't have and when
someone comes in per se meaning
representing yourself
people don't think of these things
and so it didn't happen
um
what would you recommend I'll give you a
be me that would be you and move the mic
to your
face please
but that's easier okay
hi hi my name is Cindy Smith oh good
morning fine a little bit louder a
little bit closer most of the ears up
here over 70.
well some of the years sorry
good morning good morning
my name is Cindy Smith the mother of
Lindsay Smith and I humbly request you
hear my recommendations for courts to
more properly handle domestic violence
cases
I would like to regress and give you a
very brief
opinion of the decision not to Grant the
restraining order
I believe this decision was capricious
negligent and possibly an unwitting
accomplice let me explain
capricious you're going to hear from a
tiny little woman
who was given a seven year restraining
order
by the same judge
or Facebook posts
negligent
there may have been
things she missed
the pictures although they were given to
her
um
warning signs
questions that should cause pause she
should pause about some of the things
she heard
and I will get to the unwitting
accomplice
she was granted a 30-day restraining
order based on pictures of bruises all
over her body texts and a letter from
her boss who received phone calls at
least two
from the perp telling lies an attempt to
get her fired some of this was years old
some only a few months
she also reported being a sex slave
but on the day of the second hearing
Lindsay learned she had to have new
evidence newer than a few months
which he didn't have
um
I don't want to continue on the
unwitting accomplice because if Polly
had read reports she would have read
that the cop told Lindsay this was a
landlord tenant issue
we also don't know what the port told
the police because he did give the
impression of a good old boy just trying
to help
nonetheless in the 30 days between
hearings and until the shooting Lindsay
was in flight mode she traveled to
California and Miami and Newport to see
friends and know she couldn't afford it
it was all on credit
both Lindsay and her roommates in
Hampton moved out temporarily because
they were fearful
Lindsay psychiatrist and therapist
repeatedly told her that he would
eventually kill her because of his
threats of getting her fired hadn't
produced the desired
effects and he was losing control of her
as she was recovering in Therapies
so my recommendation for the future DV
domestic violent cases would be to take
the onus off of the victim
to prove dangerousness
I emphasize victim should not have the
sole onus to prove someone's
dangerousness
victims like Lindsay do not always think
clearly
they can provide some evidence
but they aren't qualified
neither
perhaps are most judges
judges no laws and how to apply them
after the crime but they don't
understand human behavior they're not
trained
experienced psychologists are therapists
are
thus I offer
in the 30 days between restraining
orders
the courts could have hired hired a
panel of forensic psychologists or
therapist to interview both parties
they can look at backgrounds such as
education job history stability
possibly administer some personality
inventories
possibly contact
the plank the people's therapists of
both parties I'm guessing most victims
have therapists or counselors I'm not
sure Lindsay did
wasn't anyone uninterested and what
Lindsay meant by the term sexling no one
asked
but I understand why because it's all
public
and fodder fur the news
psychologists understand that past
behavior is the best indicator of future
performance
thank you for your time
representative
I want to thank you both for coming in I
can only imagine thank you Mr chairman
for letting me ask my question I want to
thank you both for coming in I can only
imagine how incredibly difficult that is
for you and I really appreciate that you
took the time
when you first contacted the police may
I ask what prompted you at the time to
contact them what were you reporting had
happened
sorry
he had just given me a basically a Tour
de France of his gun collection
and he had been sending me text messages
that
said things like
um
you're going to pay I'm going to make
you pay
and when I told him that he wasn't
allowed to talk to me because I was
afraid of him
he said I can't hear you my life would
be over
which in hindsight was good foresight
that he
had been brewing a murder suicide
in hindsight he also said
he when he showed her the his gun
collection he had
followed her and waited for her in
Marblehead Massachusetts
um
and he he made her
go to a public park and he displayed
them to her as I recall Lindsay telling
me this
um and she was breaking up with him and
she was trying to get away
and
that is his why and he wouldn't leave
he also said that he was going to f up
her life
that everything she thought was right
and good would be no longer
he said nothing would ever be okay again
yes follow-up thank you Mr chairman
when he showed you the weapons was it in
a manner that was that you perceived to
be threatening you when he or to in a
form that was meant to uh cause cause
you to be in fear
he phrased it as though he just wanted
to show me his like it was a show and
tell
how it made me feel was extremely
fearful
and I believe it was intended to be
threatening
when the restraining order the 30-day
restraining order was put in place
he sold I guess his guns to his brother
which is why he did not have them
anymore
in which y he bought the other one
anyone else
Madam Vice chair
thank you very much uh for your
testimony and I want to specifically
thank you
for the the uh suggestion you gave
um
I found that to be right on point and
very very helpful no one in this room
um
feels good about
what you have gone through and I'm sure
of that and then the question is where
do we go from here your suggestion is
something that I think will be very
important to this committee and the
committee will give due diligence I
wonder do you have any other suggestions
that you would like to make
um to try to
um
so that all the parties involved can
do the best job possible with we have
issues with the separate I mean there's
the police and that was one component
and then they're the courts and that's
another component
um
you've had experience that some of us
have never had and never want to have
I I have no other
thoughts about this this well thank you
again for that for that suggestion do
you have a copy of your testimony that
you could provide to us
yeah okay if you would uh do you have a
question I'm sorry
you're not done yet
um representative Greg hi thank you Mr
chairman I apologize for my tardiness
today and I will go back and watch the
extent of yours thank you so much for
coming in today I understand the
vulnerability that it takes to even
rehash all of that so thank you so much
and it's so important because there are
very few survivors
that are able to go and tell their story
like that I guess my one question
because we're looking at the courts and
stuff is for your case and I know that
domestic violence cases violence cases
are incredibly hard actually to prove
and that onus is I mean it really is
very hard because a lot of time abusers
will a claim abuse but they also you
know are very charming and that's kind
of how you get into that but is there
anything within the courts that when you
were trying to prove your case that you
feel like was a true Miss I know we
talked about you know having a panel or
whatever else but
that you were supported as far as like
what you knew you needed to provide is
there a Miss there that like you know
you should have provided this or they
told you later that you should have had
that that maybe
um that there was just a Miss there with
the courts
well I I did meet with an advocate prior
to the hearing and she helped me fill
out a form which then looked as though
it was written in the third person and
so I don't think that it was very
helpful to anyone
and then she did not show up to support
me and the day of so that was
disappointing
I would offer that
my husband
before we left within a week before a
week went to the second hearing as he
said do we need a lawyer
and Lindsay said no I've got somebody
coming and of course
we didn't know you needed a lawyer
why would we need a lawyer we were she
was a victim
yeah
I've written down but I would I would
recommend that to everybody to bring a
lawyer I've written down a few other
things besides judicial education in
psychology of abuse victimhood stalking
psychological slavery I also wrote down
that the court system should consider
having a psychologist
if not on staff then on ready retainer
to speak to people I also put down here
consider a new protocol
under what circumstances the court on
its own would decide if this needs to be
kicked up to criminal in other words not
make the litigant right think of it but
it should be a protocol in place and
then thirdly
um
you know lawyers are expensive I had a
Higher One recently
but going pro se has its
downside as well I'm wondering if there
were a document that was put together on
what you need to know if you're seeking
a restraining order and lists several
things of the collective wisdom of
people who figured it out or lawyers who
know what should be on it that could be
given to somebody who then wishes to go
through this
yes
there was the only thing I was directed
to was a page on a website
and
it was somewhat informative but
I agree with my mother that I probably
needed a lawyer
to actually
any other questions representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I wanted to clarify
after you contacted the police
department did they send you down to the
police to the court to fill out the form
on your own without helping you and then
who was it that did help you fill out
the form was it a specific agency or was
it the court
The Advocate I believe filled out the
form and that is it was filled out in
this third person manner
like referring to myself as Lindsay
instead of I
and it made it very confusing for the
judge I think she mentioned that
yeah follow up
um who was was The Advocate from the
court or from an agency or do you do you
know where the advocate was from or not
sure I am not sure the police just said
somebody would be calling me
okay so the police put you in when you
contacted the police they put you in
touch with an advocate who met you at
the courthouse and helped you fill out
this form
yes
thank you
anyone else
once again thank you so much thank you
so much uh this is thank you incredibly
helpful to us thank you
okay she hasn't been back
just okay
uh we are hoping the heat will turn on
chair recognizes destiny barad
and uh with the previous uh testifiers
please give us a a copy you can bring it
around take it around to representative
Greg
I'm sorry I created a traffic jam didn't
I I'm sorry
we'll work it out
at least it's not Boston
good man morning Mr chair and committee
my name is Destiny Berard any big system
whether it's courts or police or big
government agencies is going to have
some bad apples in it even if it's an
otherwise okay system obviously we'd
like to hope that police could help us
with domestic violence but in my case
one of those police officers was a bad
apple I was hesitant to come forward
before now because I dated a
Massachusetts police officer but when
Massachusetts just released its new
police misconduct database I learned for
the very first time that my ex had been
formally disciplined for excessive use
of force
oh sorry
that's right I dated a cop with a gun
who had been formally disciplined for
excessive use of force when our
relationship ended he threatened me with
his authority of being a police officer
and that is very familiar with how the
system works and his ability to
manipulate and abuse it if needed toward
the end I was trying to salvage the
relationship but he didn't like the text
he was getting from me he was also
worried about his job because of things
I knew he had done wrong at work
I live in Massachusetts but when he
couldn't manipulate the system in
Massachusetts to get an order against me
he went jurisdiction shopping and
managed to get a civil order against me
in New Hampshire a family court judge
granted a six foot one weapon-carrying
police officer in order of protection
against a four foot ten unarmed woman It
is believed it is because he lived here
and because New Hampshire Family Court
judges seemed to get to do what whatever
they want there
so how am I subject to a New Hampshire
restraining order even though I'm not a
citizen of your state and I can't even
vote for any of you
if your job is to fix New Hampshire laws
then please fix them because they're way
too easy for an abuser to manipulate and
while judge Polly Hall keeps extending
the order indefinitely your your laws
are affecting people like myself who
don't even live here
so basically it's
the same you know we've dealt with the
same judge and but it's almost the
opposite situation where
he was granted an order on absolutely
nothing from the same judge and one
thing that I see being a huge problem is
that he once you get a restraining order
because I didn't show up for the first
hearing because I was intimidated by him
so not showing up for that order when I
did show up for the extension I wasn't
allowed to show anything from the past
you know the relationship the abuse of
nature on his part they don't the judge
isn't interested in that it's only from
that point forward
you know and at that point we weren't in
a relationship but he was still being
granted these orders I'm not sure she
stated that she had a seven year
restraining order against her
because of Facebook posts and simple as
that right
and it just keeps getting continued
where you know Lindsay the microphone
can be completely different
you know I even presented photos of
Lindsay
and then compared to my Facebook
images that granted a five-year
extension and just it doesn't add up
that you know somebody can there was
just there's no Rhyme or Reason to how
they're granted at all
in my opinion
that would be the capriciousness it so
the gist of it is the big question of
how evidence is evaluated
in granting or not granting a
restraining order that's the big picture
right and just the fact that
once you're it's almost like who gets
there first
which is usually the abuser because
that's what they want they want to get
there first so they can have the
narrative
and once that they get there the victim
has no there's like nothing we can do at
that point the judge is already set on
what they've seen from
the first person that was there and it's
like tunnel vision they don't
they don't look beyond that and that was
a huge problem because I know for a fact
if I was able to present the abuse that
I went through it would have been a
completely different story but they
don't allow that
okay that's helpful that is helpful
anyone have question
representative catab thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for coming in for
taking my question so I just so I'm
understanding correctly the initial
hearing to give the restraining order is
it correct that you didn't attend and so
that's why at the subsequent continuance
hearing you weren't allowed to submit
the evidence correct thank you you're
welcome what was the reason for your
non-attendance at the first tearing
because throughout the relationship he
continuously threatened me that he's a
cop and he knows the way you know he
knows how to do things in court and
even his initial
um
filing the one that I didn't show up to
still does not
fall under any of the requirements to
get a restraining order and he did
somehow
any other questions
thank you for coming to us sorry
I only do that this way now I'm doing it
this way
thank you thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you for your testimony now how long were
you dating prior to uh this
um about three and a half years three
and a half years
and um
what what was the just of the Facebook
um just about a broken heart and
betrayal
those were the quotes that he brought
into
to show the judge that he was annoyed
with your broken heart betrayal okay
great thank you
yes please
thank you for taking my question
um so
um you both
um lived in Massachusetts he
I live in Massachusetts he lived in
Massachusetts and New Hampshire but he's
in Massachusetts
so he first went to Massachusetts trying
to get an order but they saw right
through him and that's why he came to
New Hampshire and was able to get one so
was his residence in in Massachusetts or
was it in New Hampshire it was in New
Hampshire at the time
thank you for your testimony thank you
the chair recognizes Drew Cullen
test one two
I am Andrew Cullen a free person
residing in Marlborough New Hampshire
some background on The Graduate of the
University of New Hampshire former
graduate student of the same University
a U.S marine veteran a homeowner a
business owner Christian and father I've
been a litigant and family law System
since the summer of 2017.
and I have filed two New Hampshire
Supreme Court appeals as a pro se
appellant my current appeal
2022-0445 will be reviewed by the court
on the 21st
that appeal deals with the First
Amendment religious protection and
parental medical decision-making rights
I have no criminal record and have 30
percent parenting time
for my testimony I will suggest several
fixes for New Hampshire family law and
if the legislature has the courage to
protect basic civil rights and follow
the law of the land the U.S and state
constitutions we will be better for it
these reforms ought to be amended to RSA
461 immediately Justice delayed is
Justice denied
one presumption of equal parenting
parental decision making throughout the
child's life to presumption of equal
parenting time throughout the child's
life appeals by right mandatory appeals
for family law cases for all orders and
Decisions by the courts currently New
Hampshire residents only have mandatory
appeals for 30 days following the first
set of orders however cases are allowed
to be reopened indefinitely resulting in
new orders which are then discretionary
Appeals
family law litigants will be recognized
as having a right to Rules of Evidence
and right to a jury of their peers
family laws currently administrating
criminal fines and penalties with no
jury trial this is unjust
all complaints of family law judges will
be mandatorily investigated by the
judicial conduct committee and
investigations will be made public
sunlight is the best disinfectant
RSA 458c child support guidelines
requires a complete overhaul as it
stands one person a parent with less
than 50 percent parenting time pays the
other parent whether the 51 or more
parent earns more or refuses to work
this is abusive unjust and clearly
unequal protections of the law
all family law judges appear to be
violating federal law 18 U.S Code
paragraph 242 deprivation of rights
under the color of law I suggest you get
a federal prosecutor on this issue
no additional Justice seats currently at
the cost of approximately two hundred
thousand dollars a year will be
recommended we need rights upheld the
law upheld more money means more
problems
the Supreme Court of New Hampshire is
reviewing whether the denial of my
parental rights regarding medical
decision making for vaccines is lawful
as I mentioned earlier my first
amendment religious rights have been
blatantly violated New Hampshire state
law RSA 141c and 20 have been overridden
in federal law 18 USC 242 has been
violated by the family law judge the
medical procedure I objected to my child
receiving is not mandated by law for
attending school and yet none of that
seems to matter because family law
judges currently have few repercussions
and few limits on their power
in closing it is my belief New Hampshire
family law is an unjust court system
children are denied equal access to a
parent and their side of the family
absent indictment of a crime and jury
trial judges have few repercussions for
their actions child support guidelines
are bankrupting one party for having
percentages less time with their child
the court system appears to be unjust
and must be reformed if this legislature
fails to uphold the rights of the free
people of New Hampshire we will have no
choice than to claim relief in article
10 of the New Hampshire Constitution
right of Revolution Live Free or Die
family law is the worst of evils
anyone have a question for Mr Cullen
uh do you have a copy of that because if
you do we'll read it and we will funnel
at least some of it into the different
subgroup that we'll be looking at things
I'll email it over I'm sorry I will
email it over okay
um equal parenting issue is one that is
presently before us children and family
law committee will be looking uh in a
work session uh next month at House Bill
185 on that kind of an issue so it's a
live topic for us which doesn't mean
this group may not also take a a look at
it but a few of the things you've
touched on
are already in the hopper and a few more
may become so because of your testimony
today we await it
thank you thank you
and as for the legislature having
courage I'm only Air Force I'm not a
marine so I'll try
The Honorable Betty gay
thank you Mr chairman
and thank you all for how much I know
you care about this subject
it can be very heart-wrenching
I'm just going to read you just
the title of about 17 issues that I've
identified from talking to people who
are troubled by what happened in Family
Court
um and I can send you more detail but
for my five minutes I just figured this
would be
I would touch on many subjects and
hopefully many of you have already been
con concerned about them
a new one for me was we need to
authorize enforcement of court orders
but the police are state troopers or the
sheriff's department right now if you go
to pick up your child for your
visitation that's guaranteed in court
order the police will tell you that's a
court issue we don't do that go back to
court
you're holding a court order
how is that going to change if you go
back to court
we need to create an appeals process for
Family Court litigants to address
incorrect statements of fact in court
orders right now we don't have any way
to request it de novo
we can most people don't know you can
ask to reopen the case because right now
most people have no recourse when they
get out of the judge's decision and it's
got
I don't know what to call them they're
not facts they're incorrect facts that
the decision is based on
when domestic violence is alleged
prosecuted in Criminal Court
we have the problem of both people who
are victims not being believed or
advised
and it shouldn't be in family court it's
a crime we also have the problem of
people thinking that if they accuse if
they're getting a divorce if they accuse
the other person of domestic violence
they could get a better deal and then
then after they swayed the pinions then
they dropped the charges you're going to
need to give less commentary you said
you have 17 you've only done three or
four and you're running out of time okay
so both things both false and accurate
need a processed cutie uh stop courts
from ordering months of counseling in
the mistaken view that domestic abuse is
a disagreement between equals
you can bankrupt people especially if
you order reunification therapy which is
not covered by insurance and also we
have an RSA that prescribes that you're
supposed to order if you order cons uh
counseling it's supposed to be what
their insurance covers CFL is looking at
that one next month as well in work
session great
make shared parenting the default for
child custody
requiring investigation into reasons
requiring investigations into reasons
given to deny 50 50. uh obviously
domestic abuse would be a reason not to
give it only whoops only a point
judges
who have only appoint Family Court
judges uh people who have experience
this was advised to Children family law
well actually the judge came here and
said that uh thanks to marjorie's
representative Margie's request for what
he had advised so he said just choose
people to be judges who have experience
abide by the U.S Constitution's Bill of
Rights
I think we already have heard people
testify that they don't have rights you
have more rights going being charged
with a crime and going in Criminal Court
and you don't have the right to a speedy
trial either
so without without the right to give
evidence and testimony in defense of you
that is a violation of constitutional
rights
take family court judges off the circuit
so they only preside over family court
cases and that will help restore the RSA
that prescribes one family one judge I
have met many families who have met five
judges
so they don't have a continuation
they're not familiar with the case
continue child support when the amount
is awaiting a hearing in some cases it's
just terminated well that's not very
fair to the children or the person who's
taking care of them
but when child support stops due to a
job loss or a catastrophic illness Grant
a hearing within two weeks
establish a statistics collection on
family court cases on pertinent subjects
like what percentage of children are
ordered never to see both parents
audit the State child support collection
Services they keep making mistakes and
charging people who may be a week or
maybe as much as a month behind and
taking their driver's license or
threatening to take the driver's license
whereas other people are months in
arrears and play the game of not paying
up until the person they're supposed to
pay to pay gets a hearing and then they
pay up the week before so they're not
guilty but there's no penalty this is a
awful game
establish one or more JCC oversight
Boards of legislators and citizens who
have no court connections to review
litigant claims currently almost all
claims get the same no-finding response
and that goes for gal filings too
judge poly Hall is still a judge
allow Family Court judges to overrule
family court rules only when ignoring
the rule is fair to both parties
and require the recusal of a judge when
one of the litigants is represented by
his or her current or pass Law Firm that
is just inherent bias
how many seconds have I gone over
um I don't know I wasn't counting this
is this is very helpful thank you and I
do have the more detail in the handout
um I'd like to see that send me 17
separate emails please
uh I think you'd like that's not for
everybody that's just for you here
um because that way I can put them in
files easily rather than busting things
up okay I will do that does everybody
want that
okay I'll hand out I'll hand out the
summary now but I'll I'll send send you
that see this is the kind today has been
the kind of thing I've been looking for
specific
issues of alleged problems
without rehashing a case it really helps
though that you've heard other people
talk about the same issue so it's not
just one person coming up and saying I
think this you know so much will await
your emails thank you and she recognizes
Katrina Heinrich
thank you and good morning esteem
committee and Mr chair
um
JD just gave you several
um oh I'm sorry JD you just gave you
several handouts I guess is the best
work for them
um
I wanted to open with
saying just a simple acknowledgment
which I can do better with glasses on
The Voice
of testimony is cumulative
experiences research and at times
repetitive voices on this particular
subject as well as any other related
topic
having contributed to seeking a solution
to Justice
it would be remiss to not acknowledge
the countless
negative experiences that have led to
the dedicated efforts of legislators
like you
the citizens I'm just going to remind
you you've got five minutes thank you
very much I know you love us
um
it is a thank you it is a thank you
yeah as much as I hate to interrupt that
yeah this is this is actually very short
okay keep it on
so what I've done is I have looked at
the numerical and the mathematics
that apply to Family Court such as
accounting regulations title 4D the
formulas
um these are pieces that consistently
are missing and is part of the failures
of what appears to be the due process
pieces
uh
the patterns of the problems suggest
that the various roles and silos of
service and service providers associated
with the processes and procedures and
the resources
are part of the problem
understanding the problem and seeking
the solutions
research and experiences suggesting that
the issue design is complex by way of
outside Source contributors
the problem appears to be external
influences on economics
on the executive branch
and from title IV D Money prospects
the use of systems to analyze family
case details has potential options that
evolve into complex difficult and at
times contentious motivations
the split Direction in this situation
is the case management road maps
and it splits and it puts a position
where you're either serving New
Hampshire families
or you're providing service to
institutional stakeholders
there's various research there's
accounting requirements for title 4D
there's expedited processes
there's functions that are necessary
in Family Court a repetitive objection
is the fails
to pass a reasonable justification
because of New Hampshire rule 2.2 which
we've all talked about a lot
um but by default
the litigant loses loss of guaranteed
ability to present evidence as defined
in the 14th Amendment
so suspend the rule of evidence and by
default the loss is guaranteed
this is a common
Family Court complaint of
unsubstantiated narratives being used
artificially manufactured
standards of perjury gaslighting fraud
the artificial narratives are extremely
harmful to the families and here we are
as recent as May 5th 2023 the governor's
Commission on domestic violence sexual
assault and stalking
had discussions that highlighted
and in no particular order
the issues of Family Court weaponizing
the family court process abuse of
processes expunging errors lying and
referencing gaps that are in the process
there's various laws and I have about 10
sitting in front of me I'm not going to
quote them
that our local New Hampshire rsas
clearly Federal and some criminal code
that is consistently being
abused
the solution it appears
historical and current operations are
just crushing I mean crushing
a vast number of families in New
Hampshire year after year including
extensive harm to children
the failures of due process appear to
not meet the family needs or title 4D
requirements
current operations appeared to and do
establish winners and losers all to
facilitate the state benefits to the
maximum and the extent which equates to
title 4D
the solution the few minutes you have I
hope I think you you just said the word
over me and that's good because this is
all
yep big Theory and not helpful it's
Preparatory it is not helpful we need
specific recommendations the references
and appendix that I've attached to this
for you
do explain that in detail what
oh I'm sorry we didn't pass out no these
are your copies oh
okay I do have your copies can we have
our copies absolutely thank you for my
apology Dana would you mind
okay
my apologies on that I I gave everything
to JD and didn't think about it
yes those are all for me yes those are
supporting just supporting pieces
so back to the solution I did put them
as as in relevant order as I could
um
the handouts that you have Risky
Business which highlighted how the New
Hampshire courts was going to become a
business entity
um the trends appendix two three and
four the future of unified Family Court
s in the predictive algorithms and the
state of New Hampshire requested action
document
in the end after looking at the numbers
and doing all the pieces which you now
have a lot of That Base information
the solution
really appears to be
that we need to have more mediation
and anything that doesn't work in
mediation needs to go to criminal and
civil court because that's where this
belong
apply the Rules of Evidence
the solution this closed Family Court
and that's it thank you any questions
my esteemed Vice chair
my esteemed chair I'm trying to get the
word c in here so we'll feel warmer yeah
I tried again by the way but
um
Miss Heimer could you tell me who are
you representing today
myself and every other person that's
been in here testifying
and um I mean you have some very
if I could continue you have some very
detailed weighty materials that you that
you gave us and so I guess I I'd like to
have a a little more sense of you and
um
kind of what brought you here
experience and background
um education but most of all the
experience of actually
going through the family court process
for over a decade
and then to come here
and listen to story after Story some
more tragic some less tragic
some shorter some longer
it laid a pattern a very clear pattern
and I can literally
almost every case I've heard to some
extent overlay
the various procedures and processes
that end you up
with the title for dmath
with the requirements of accounting that
are missing that I'm looking for that I
can't seem to get from the state there's
there's a variety of issues that just
added up and math is math
thank you very much for that answer
anything else anyone else
saying none thank you so much thank you
chair recognizes the honorable danitsa
thank you Mr chairman thank you to
members of the committee for
for the record I'm uh former
representative Dan Itza uh formerly of
Fremont uh if I may just before I begin
what you don't realize is that Ms
Heinrich before all of this happened to
her she was a bank vice president
and that's why she has the perspective
that she has and why she has the
analytical skills that she has
that helped her through the
aftermath of surviving the family courts
and doing something about it what I'd
like to present today
is a history because everything has to
be
done in historical context
the
family courts began in New Hampshire in
1995 the bill was submitted by
representative Weiler
the purpose of the family courts was at
the time divorce was heard in District
Court
and the family is sitting there waiting
for their hearing we're also sitting
there with Petty criminals and the whole
idea of family courts that swept Across
the Nation in the mid 90s was to get the
families out of the company of petty
criminals
it began in rockhamp County and Grafton
County as a pilot program
and because there's a pilot program and
you had now had a new court and all the
other uh existing laws were designed for
District Court
in their Equity jurisdiction Equity is
when a court has the power to order you
to do something to sell your house to
divide your property that's what Equity
Court means
as opposed to Criminal Court which is
deals purely with crime and punishment
the family court rules their Equity
jurisdiction began and still does begin
with
a lot of the contrary notwithstanding
and that means that whatever laws May on
the book may be on the books don't
affect what they do
and that kind of made sense when when uh
family court was a new startup pilot
program and you didn't know what
the rules were going to be
when I came to the legislature in 2001
it was a story of fathers separated from
their children that's the way the state
laws were constructed
parent fathers were
consistently uh withdrawn from their
children the state state practice
parental and alienation
um in 2003 we expanded it to two more
counties
in 2005 and I should say that there was
a substantial industry in among the
legal community in fathers attempting to
regain contact with their children there
was a business there
in 2005 we revamped our custody laws so
that they were no longer custody laws it
was parenting time
and we made every effort to move things
from litigation to go to uh negotiation
we to make sure that both parents would
have contact with their children
and unfortunately this
really blew the bottom out of the
industry
but it didn't take them long
to create a new methodology
the new methodology is you take one
parent you give them pretty much all
custody
and then you inspire the other parent to
regain custody
and then you have somebody fighting to
get and somebody fighting to keep
and you create an event that goes on for
two three five years now it's not really
a large percentage it's less than 10
percent of the divorces that involve
this kind of interplay
but when there's seven thousand divorces
a year in New Hampshire and that means
that 700 are subject to this interplay
and they last five to ten years you can
see there's a substantial number of
families that are in this interplay
being relegated to therapies and returns
to court and returns to court and
returns to court
in uh
2009 we took the family court Statewide
in 2012 we
revamped the courts
and now we have the circuit courts and
the circuit courts include the Probate
Court the district court and the family
court
typically District Court holds criminal
issues and Family Court held civil
issues and Probate Court held issues of
legacy and uh guardianship things like
that
now a funny thing happened and you have
two victims of this in the courtroom
today in the hearing room today in 2014
the family Branch was also given
occasional jurisdiction over domestic
violence prior to that domestic violence
is an assault it's a crime it was
handled by The District Court
The District Court though it does have
Equity jurisdiction in some of its cases
it has rules of equity it has a a set of
laws that say this is how you handle
cases
remember over in Family Court a lot of
the contrary notwithstanding no state
law really holds
and in the interest of the Justice the
judge May waive any rule not in statute
so
nada
since 2014 domestic violence violence
cases have shifted from District Court
where there are rules and Rules of
Evidence
to Family Court where there are no rules
kind of runs like a Bruce Willis movie
rule one there are no rules
uh in 2015
when I was in the family uh
children family law committee the Chief
Justice of the circuit court and of the
family court came in and they told us
something very interesting
they could tell
in the first preliminary hearing when
they go in they get told this is what
the process for divorce is they could
identify those 10 percent of the cases
that we would become complex cases
their marks were identified
the
there's there's one thing very
definitely that you can do
is take out that one little phrase law
to the contrary notwithstanding
that exists in their jurisdiction of
cases which means they can really take
any case they want
and that's uh 490d
colon 2 and
what is the letter 490 490 D Dash D
colon two and colon 3. and that same
little introductory phrase which says is
a lot of the contrary notwithstanding
read in spite of any law to the contrary
they can do what follows and what
follows is to hear these cases
and in two and in three uh how what
rules they have to follow
then after you've gotten the rid of
those
two phrase that same phrase twice
I would take things that involve real
crime like domestic violence I would
take them out of family court and put
them into District Court
which is
equipped and organized to handle
low level criminal cases
and I would create a system of laws and
family court
that says this is these are the types of
evidence that are required
and uh I I will be happy to make sure
some ideas get put in but
that's what you need to do you that you
have to take away the there are no rules
aspect
you need to take account of what rules
court rules are being routinely or
capriciously discarded
I mean if there's a rule that never gets
applied maybe it shouldn't be there
if there's a rule that gets discarded
and set in a manner that it skews the
outcome of cases like the person for
whom it only always gets discarded is
always the person that wins
you need to do something about it
will you email us with the specifics uh
like on 490d2 and 3 and take crimes on a
family court you're in your conclusion I
I really appreciate the history
background to this a lot of stuff I've
learned here today and now at the end of
your testimony you're making
recommendations if you could email us I
would be honored to and would you take
questions of course okay
foreign
seeing none thank you so much and yeah
shoot this to us we are in the process
of
um coming up with i i liken it to
proto-planetary matter in the vast
universe that circles around planets
we're we're coming up with seven planets
sorry Neptune and Pluto um and getting
people assigned to those so we're taking
all of the stuff that's come in and
putting it in its proper place that's
what we're doing thank you
that concludes our hearing of public
testimony
and um
thank you so much this was probably I
think about the best session we've ever
had
I think the early people testify
but this this puts a cherry on the
Sunday
now you're going to be punching up that
thing for me here uh just a reminder to
everyone here the special committee
meets next on October 3rd 9 30 it will
be a general work session I believe
um you all got an email or two from me
indicating
um
what those different topics will be this
doesn't mean one might jump out at us in
a few weeks and we realize oh we should
do that one but generally speaking I
think we've got the general topics I've
also pretty much heard from you as to
what work groups you would like to be
part of
some of these topics I think will be
done very quickly some of them are going
to take quite a while
some of them I think again we will
simply be making recommendations to the
Judiciary System some of them we will be
putting legislation in
and in terms of looks like this one will
be legislation
I have been told by the speaker
that in cases like special committees
the
submission period for bills is extended
we all know this is Bill submission week
but we will probably have six or eight
weeks more it will go to a committee of
the house and they will decide whether
they'll let it in or not and the speaker
said
most of the times they do because they
know this is this work product done here
but if it does look like early November
we're just not there yet
um we can wait I don't want bad stuff
done
um
so with that in mind could you uh slide
that um wonderful device over here
okay Mr chair yes if I could while
you're
organizing that I'd also like to point
out to the public that a number of bills
were filed
last this year and assigned to children
and family law children and family law
retained those bills
and therefore still have to act on them
and so those bills I as I understand
having the benefit of you sharing both
this committee and that will be reviewed
by children and family law and any
number of them do address issues that
had been brought before us here
so those are on a slightly different
timeline children and family law will
look at them and get them in before
Thanksgiving and with a final
recommendation for a vote and the full
house would be voting on them starting
in January so you have kind of three
different
schedules for how these bills are going
to be addressed and of course there's no
schedule for addressing Communications
between the legislature and the
Judiciary
thank you so much that leads me to tell
you what bills have been scheduled for
children and family law retain bills
this is on September 26 Tuesday
children and family law retained bill
618.
relative to wage garnishment with child
support payments
10 15.
retained Bill relative to parental
access to a minor child's medical
records
11 o'clock
requiring an attorney
for a child who is the subject of a
proceeding in a family court case that's
Tuesday Morning September 26th
on
Tuesday afternoon
October 3rd
one o'clock
retain Bill relative to the
determination of parental rights and
responsibilities based on shared
parenting and shared access to the
child's records
at two o'clock retained House Bill 455
relative to creating a new state cause
of action and special findings for
Abused neglected and abandoned children
seeking special immigrant juvenile
status under federal law and at three
o'clock
retain Bill 306 relative to prohibiting
reunification therapy
now there's three more that have not
been scheduled yet because they are very
much in the Wheelhouse of what we are
doing
the uh five people in children and
family law who will be addressing those
retained bills are also each one of them
members of this committee so we've get
that benefit of
um overlap so
follow the house record or the record
online all of the information I just
gave I am reading from the house record
when more information is available as to
when what hi how who he that will be in
the record as well
now for the committee
we have one group
that will be looking at the Guardians at
Litem slash parenting coordinator role
funding training the issues surrounding
mental health evaluation
potential benefit of social worker
psychologists rather than attorneys how
States handle
gal domestic violence matter now does
this mean somebody's moving
and interestingly we will be looking at
that here
but representative catab who I asked to
chair that group has also put an LSR in
so we're running in some parallel tracks
which can be a little confusing but I
think it's pretty helpful also
representatives Greg and long are part
of this is there anyone else who wishes
to be part of that
is that true
okay
you have been added that's why we're
doing this
wow
she's already on it oh yeah you're on it
that's right here
ones okay now uh group two judicial
training education
supervision
accountability this reviews RSA 490 F6
uh chairing this is representative Smith
also representatives
catablanza and Pearson
there's also an LSR that has been
entered on this as well
thank you
okay uh anyone else wish to be in on
that
little group okay
also number three forms
how did I get on that can they be
improved particularly to make them
user-friendly for those representing
themselves how can staff best assist the
public without crossing the line to
provide legal counsel
remember some of us went to Nashua and
we saw some forms and they were not as
user friendly as they could have been on
this chairing is I've asked
representative Greg to chair that also
representative McMahon and somebody
appointed me as well okay if we can go
up slide that up here thank you
is that true
you want to be on there okay
ball
we dropped the ball
wow okay
uh number four rules of evidence
and having Discovery regulations
enforced
I guess I pointed me to that also
representative McMahon is is there
anybody else in here is there a line
under that we really would like a couple
more people on that if we can have it
anybody else like Rules of Evidence
you know I mean if you've got family oh
let's just long okay anybody who has a
family member who's
a judge might want to help us out here
thank you
representative Greg as well
on four
okay let's let's put Greg up in before
we forget huh
all right now explain please what we
mean what we mean here by meetings to
discuss so we have four work groups
for now
and explain what yeah so uh
chairman Pearson you had also authorized
a discussion on child support we've had
issues with getting agreement between
the house and the senate in years past
we really haven't made any meaningful
change since 2007 and so uh rep Smith
and I will be meeting with Senator
Carson to
see what we can uh
negotiate for a path forward and then
um
regarding domestic violence
you agreed for a meeting between rep
Smith and Rhett Manos who's actually
from the Judiciary Committee and is also
a family law attorney so has
um
much background in some of this and so
we'll be meeting to discuss what uh
we may be able to come up with and that
may end up turning into a subcommittee
of its own just like the child support
one may yes and I did put in um
so some of these I did go ahead and try
and do as much homework as I possibly
could just to put in some lsrs that I
thought were
based on a lot much of what we heard
um and they can absolutely I'm
absolutely open to amending them if we
come up with you know some changes that
we should
um make but I wanted to have us to have
a starting place because I recognize
that it's difficult uh
to put something together so I thought
it would be easier if we just had
somewhere to stand this is why as a as
an example
um I would I held back one of the sununu
center bills simply in case we needed it
and you and I have the committee that's
going to deal with that in about 12
seconds because it's not needed anymore
but had it been we had it in our hand
and we didn't have to get special waving
of rules which plow ahead so that's what
we've got here too if we wind up with
parallel tracks I hope they'll talk with
each other we may wind up saying okay we
don't really need all of this we won't
as a special committee put anything in
because we can put it in kind of any
time
or what but it gives us more options uh
anything else down here
um so the neutral case evaluation
expansion that was already being
expanded so to all the courts so we
didn't feel there was a need to do
anything with it
um equal parenting time there's the bill
that you mentioned House Bill 185 FM
that's been retained you already told us
the date that that meeting will be
um and then we didn't end up uh
forming ignore these two because these
are already up above we didn't end up
forming anything on timelines just
because
that really is a a court function and
there there have been a few
um
cases where there's
you know limited amount of oversight
that we can give into the Judiciary but
also I think we need to to keep in mind
that when we put a timeline for
something it pushes a timeline for
something else so they can only fit in
certain number of cases in a certain
amount of days so for now
we were holding off of the real way to
address this is more judges and we've
put seven in the budget for this
two-year cycle that's a third of what an
evaluative committee came up with
um I am hoping that in the next budget
we'll have at least seven additional
that's what will eliminate the Log Jam
I think these are these are going to be
recommendations but no committees like
recommendations from our report all
right go up one
so this one you can ignore oh no where's
the other one
um it was one I liked that I had that
seven but that is a thing on here oh
that's already up there oh yeah okay
sorry I thought that was familiar yeah
all right anybody here
um on the special committee who's
interested in jumping into any of the
work groups
um
or the ones that are not likely to be
legislative but probably recommending
things uh jump into that discussion if
you heard anything that sounds like you
uh representative gregg
well yes the work group on domestic
violence and what we're going to do with
that absolutely
I'm sorry yeah so we don't we don't have
um we haven't really come up with any
sort of uh path forward on it we're
gonna have a
discussion on it okay sure I'd love to
be part of that discussion thank you
that's what it is okay so put her name
and watch your attention I know I'm just
making sure this one's flat
okay r e
yes
I was requesting to also be formed up
okay good thank you
good
anyone else for anything else
you're out of order sir
you're out of order please you are out
of order and if necessary
thank you
all right so I think we we've got this
would you send this uh revised list out
to everybody okay good thank you and
this brings us to a close see you in
October
yeah good